what up guys welcome to the just curly
things youtube channel today i'm gonna
let my hypergamy run rampant before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos what is hypergamy
hypergamy the act of marrying or forming
a sexual relationship with a person of a
superior
superior sociological or educational
background so i always hear in the
manosphere about how women are so
hypergamous their standards are too high
and i was like maybe i should race i was
just hoping for a guy with a job taller
than me nice but you guys got me
thinking let's let it run rampant today
i'm going to be dm'ing nba players and
seeing if any response i'm shooting for
like maybe 50 nba players i don't even
watch basketball to be honest also i
don't know if any of these people have
girlfriends or wives so if you're seeing
this and you do a girlfriend or wife my
bad do i think any of them are going to
respond no
clearly not you girl my hypergamy just
got the best of me today what what
basketball team is in new york oh next
okay let's try the next
um
okay let's do this guy
r.j barrett uh what's a good pickup line
uh i'm gonna say let me cook you dinner
i can't cook but i will cross that
bridge when i get there send a picture
of me with it um oh
obi that's an odd name let me
cook you dinner what's a good what's a
better pick-up line
oh no he has a wife unsend hold on
unsend
unsent
sorry sir i didn't mean to i really
didn't mean to my bad my bad i'm not
trying to okay my sister follows this
man we better not is that a good pickup
line or is there a better one
oh this one's good i saw your girlfriend
earlier
but when i tried to give her
a hug
what was it
i bumped
in the mirror
i won't be shocked if any of these guys
respond because
i
i just feel like there's so many hotter
girls like why on earth
you know you never know
my sister follows all of these men
should i be
what's a good way to for a girl to slide
i don't i don't actually know let's do a
new pickup line um
i may not be rapunzel but you can still
pull my hair oh that's too much are you
mixed because you look half fine and
half mine
are you mixed because
you look
half fine and half
mine
i really like the eyes emoji i don't
know i just want them to know i'm making
eye contact like we're making a
i don't know i think i did it
being
being a hypergamy is a lot of work i
feel like i've been doing this forever
oh no am i banned
no they banned me
because i sent too many messages
why is instagram getting in the way my
hypergamy you guys i think i'll have to
come back so right now i did
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20 21 22.
so i'm like halfway i'll come back okay
guys you won't even believe this or
maybe you will but for me shock and awe
i got a response my hypergamy has kicked
in am i am i nba level wifey material oh
my god i always knew i was meant to be
out what the man that responded
is jordan nora
now
jordan if you're watching this i'm very
sorry
i put this conversation on blast
one he's like super tall
very attractive very much out of my
league i'm like why is this man even
responding to me i'm very confused was
my pickup line that good it had to be
the pickup line oh my god i had to be
the pickup line yeah but it looks like
he plays i think jordan i don't really
watch basketball like that um
a round two pick 45 45th overall i think
that's good wow so he he's a starter for
the bucks i'm like shocked he responded
to me not bad
not bad jordan are we gonna fall in love
now um okay just i'm like super normal i
swear anyways
i got unbanned from sending men dms i've
never heard of this guy i guess
caruso so i gotta do a good pickup line
he's got a lot alex
really good one oh my god i'll use kevin
samuels kev can you help me find
something a husband okay this guy
also followed by my sister odd
predicament we're in i'm allergic to
nuts mind if i try yours to make sure oh
no i can't do that one here's ten
dollars because the police said to pay
the fine oh my gosh that's it here is
ten dollars
because the police said
you should pay
to be
this fine
i'm so smooth i'm a smooth i'm a talker
a smoother talker i send a picture of
myself with it because
i'm gonna say i wasn't sales right so if
i'm selling me i always knew it's better
to show them a picture of the product i
think we have a misunderstanding with
the pronouns he
slashed him
i think they should
be
your slash mine
instead oh my god russell westbrook i
think i've heard of him actually is he
good he's like really good at basketball
where have i heard him from uh is that a
family that looks like it might be a
family oh yeah that's a wife and kids
nope i will be moving on from that one
carmelo anthony is that guy gotta be a
good one i'm loving opportunistically
today you know how us women do oh i got
one that says hey wanna
one v one me and spin
the bottle with the eyes and then
i'm a smooth [ __ ] who knew
all right kendrick nunn never heard of
you sir
oh my goodness i cannot do too many more
of these uh lakers okay i guess he's
cool
oh this one's smooth i would say god
bless you but it looks like he already
did
should i slide into shacks dms
i'm gonna slide into shaq's dms
[Music]
um
is he married i don't know
magic johnson i think has aids and maybe
a family so i'm gonna pass on that one
should i slide into tristan thompson's
dms i'll be like don't worry i could be
baby mom number three
okay i'm gonna say i hear you're looking
for baby mama
number four
[Music]
god i'm hilarious oh my god i'm so funny
oh he he doesn't let me receive your
messages anyways i'll keep you guys
posted within 24 hours and let you guys
know like what what is next and if
anyone else responds okay guys so i'm
about to go to bed it's been two days so
what do you guys think did i get any
responses we're about to find out i hate
to break it to you but the majority of
these men did not in fact respond i
tried to ask tristan thompson if he
wanted me to be baby mama number four
and he
sadly declined um two responses and just
you guys know this is a social
experiment i i don't actually expect
these nba players to give me the time of
day both from guys i've never heard of
um one being ej montgomery
one guy said to my picture are you in
paris hahaha are you gonna let my
hypergamy get out of control that's the
real question the second guy said oh he
said my pickup line was good which was
are you mixed sir because you look half
fine and half mine so overall what did i
learn i don't know i consider myself
pretty like normal looking girl to be
honest and i did not expect to get a
response from any nba player at all i
think they're all pretty out of my
league but yeah that was cool anyways
let me know if you guys like these type
of videos let me know am i am i coming
off too thirsty i'm not these are just
some like good fun don't forget to
subscribe i'll talk to you guys next
time